[Music]
deep fake technology has become such a
crazy thing
that recently
bank robbers were able to steal 35
million dollars by simply deep faking
their boss's voice
i apologize what's deep fake so
deep fake is when you are impersonating
the voice or likeness of somebody like a
celebrity say or somebody that you know
um using technology and it seems so
lifelike that it tricks people in real
life
there's a porno and they put like megan
fox's head on like another porn star but
it literally looks like it's a megan fox
porno now that's called deep fake yeah
oh they i like
just attached their head to it and then
they it like fills in the blanks with
megan fox yeah there's a tap too yeah
there's this tick tock channel where
it's uh
uh like not real tom cruise or something
we talked about that one on here yeah
this [ __ ] looks and talks just
like if if i didn't know i would
literally think this is tom is he is he
a doppelganger or is he really doesn't
look like him and using technology using
technology i don't even know what he
originally looks like yeah yeah there's
an app right but it's not tom cruise you
already kind of have a little likeness
to it yeah like his body type all that
yeah yeah yeah yeah talk like him and
move like at least i could find him on
instagram because i don't really have
tick-tock and there's also some good
[ __ ] of like our wives getting pretty
banged pretty hard out there
hey would you not to that though like oh
dude i'm like dude that looks better not
gonna ever do it
that guy's working on dude
it's actually steve i know the legend of
steve green oh i'm just good at
fingering though
you're really good i want to know what
it feels like yeah yeah she just she's
just the ways bro you know he's
physically capable of fingering you
right bart yes okay cool i will finger
you
oh yeah that's the guy that's crazy
that's not tom cruise and he's using
actual oh you can always tell wait
that's definitely not tom cruise no no
that's the guy breaking it down yeah
yeah let me see another one he's using
technology
i
yeah people need to intro stuff too much
here i got you bart i know what you're
talking about yeah yeah yeah yeah where
are you hey bart that's why you don't
host me
honestly that's why i do jesus christ
mark
he's better than tom cruise
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's the one i saw this is [ __ ]
crazy that's nuts dude
wait wait wait wait wait wait i want to
understand tech because he's if it's
technology to that's what is it
adjusting his face no no so it's filling
in the blanks right so like like he he
has his own face
the ai stuff is is painting tom cruise's
face onto his face because his face is
similar but he's taking like for example
like his hat or his sunglasses and he's
still like crossing over his face and
there's no like pistillation delay or
anything like that some of the bad ones
you can see it like if they turn their
head like a certain angle you could see
it kind of like no this is movie level
technologies i'm saying i didn't see i
didn't see a lot like this is like paul
walker at the end of a [ __ ] fashion
furious this is even better than paul
walker what the [ __ ]
because this came out after like this
probably came out after paula almost
always somebody doing it at home does it
better than the movie studios for some
reason i don't know why they need a job
they have a princess leia too if you
remember that yes yeah it was like whack
looking yes um but then somebody else
did it and it looks pretty legit paul
walker's like driving but then he's like
connected oh yeah yeah it's all weird
yeah that was his brother that's [ __ ]
all glittery they do that though because
i think uh when we had originally talked
about like the tom cruise guy they did
that for queen of the damned for like um
the last scene uh you had already yeah
she had already passed so they had to
use her brother for the likeliness of
like the voice and other things yeah
yeah a little boy that was like over 10
years ago so imagine now like this
and by the way disney just hired a very
um uh like one of the deep fake
youtubers because they did such a good
job that they just were like [ __ ] it
we're hiring one of these guys because
they do such a better job wow they
kicked out their
their actual workers now and they got
the youtubers they did a [ __ ] job on
princess leia i'll tell you that all
right so oh yeah check this out um
basically they were able to steal 35
million dollars by calling wow and being
like yo you got to transfer these funds
and they're like i guess with my boss
sure
and they actually so they could use
their voice yep
that's insane
okay first of all yes it's all gonna
[ __ ] everyone was working there and only
registered a voice to transfer 35
million dollars they're the loser
because you need to verify what like
yeah i don't know but like if if it's
just a [ __ ] voice then that's it
that's [ __ ] for 35 million it's a
bank it's a bank
employee that just used it yeah
that's pretty genius well imagine this
imagine your apheon crockett
and you call like jay-z's assistant and
then you tell them like yo this is
[ __ ] jade do this do this do this for
me and it's just a normal day yeah
because it rolls right to this place on
a normal day that happens to you so much
yeah and you talk to the guy so much
if it sounds like him why wouldn't you
just 35 mil is probably nothing what
does his [ __ ] not have caller id
it's just his [ __ ] doesn't have
corn
double check 35 mil if he's all if he's
a banker and he's always trading but
there's also technology where you could
have your phone
call somebody but it would be a
different number right yeah that's all
the telemarketers do all the time but
isn't there like
kind of a paper trail when you wire this
money
well yeah it's right so i mean that's
where they [ __ ] up they're working on
tracing it right now with american
investigators this is the uae right the
united united emirates are working with
american investigators to get the money
back but oh i went like over
international waters oh oh buddy they
they moved the money several times now
wow to banks across the world they're
good yeah but um it was 35. they deserve
it then and this is actually the second
known case of something like this
let's do it let's get the 2019 criminals
used ai to try to impersonate an
executive's voice to steal 243 g's
only
yeah and yeah it's not 30 small when you
think about 35 million good tester i
wasn't saying guys but yeah that's
that's the same [ __ ] ratios is when
you're trying to like transfer a little
bit of money to another wallet so you're
like let me send a test amount to make
sure it's cool yeah
it was too yeah it's like 200 g's worked
out let's try the 35 mil yeah let's go
for it let's go
that's ridiculous and honestly though
like
[Music]
props to the criminals if you [ __ ]
use some innovative [ __ ] and you're like
the first of its kind bowed out i kind
of think you deserve the win but put
yourself in their shoes for a second
whose shoes uh uh well the per the bank
manager that you humiliated on this show
okay cool i'm a [ __ ] fire myself all
right no no but put yourself in the
shoes
let's say
hypothetical situation a friend wants to
transfer you a lot of money transfer
into my bank into your bank account and
they just call you up and it sounds like
your friend like yo dude let's just do
this it's no problem rock and roll cool
why wouldn't you be into my bank
absolutely oh i see
out of my bank i will [ __ ] ask you a
billion questions 35 million dollars out
of my bank yeah yeah that's not what
you're normally looking at he's wiping
out the whole
bank account what if it's a normal thing
though he could he could he could be a
billionaire bro if you're wiping out
even two million i got a [ __ ] double
oh he's such a cheap ass
what's too big
anthony this episode is a cheapo he's a
cheapo get your [ __ ] kleenex out of
your nose and [ __ ] call me girl with
test transactions and [ __ ] it's like
come on you taught me crypto sensei
called you that explicitly you [ __ ] off
all right you [ __ ] always tell me to
touch transact not after he's like
before you bend mommy then we'll be 25
cents first to make sure it works you
gotta test it
it's even better with the water
do you test bamboo transactions
you [ __ ] get your backpack you just
wait for it
so yeah everyone's afraid of this
technology obviously because uh this is
an example of what can happen with that
deep face yeah oh 100 dude imagine
warren buffett coming out tomorrow and
just saying i'm sure i'm shorting
everything because he's such a huge
influence yeah like
they literally follow his trades like so
almost like he's almost as powerful as
nancy pelosi where they follow all her
trades now
but no they follow his trades to the t
like they everyone wants his sheets they
all want to know what he's buying
imagine him coming out tomorrow and
somebody's deep faking it and he's like
sell everything getting the [ __ ] out
yeah
for the first time
for the first time
it is what it is i feel like criminals
who innovate something or do something
for the first time that eventually
creates regulation or an example for
people to like respond to a new rule
that that's i'm like dude it is what it
is i'm not saying like go and do it i'm
just saying like that's not go and do it
dude this is how i know you've been in
the dance world too long like hey props
to them though
like you know it's not really my moves
no one agrees
props to them for making a 35 million
heist i'd like to think that the bank
deserved it that's what i'm saying
everybody who does something [ __ ]
crazy or innovative for the first time
to the point where it can't be
replicated a second time because counter
measures are put in place i say process
i just i just like props to charles
matson because nobody could replicate
that [ __ ] at first he did it
first he was the one
feel free to take it out of context i'm
just saying what you said yeah yeah he's
praising charles
if you were given a time machine the
place you would goes to find the first
pedophile but you know what you did a
good job
yeah the first one the first catholic
church okay just so you know you're
changing the game right now you don't
know it yet you're actually inspiring a
lot of people be careful because after
this we're gonna have some regulations
i'm so thankful to be on the show
cnn goes jk news
jk news promotes his host
just in case you guys weren't sure this
is where i get most of my character
number two best jk host promotes
first one is
promotes criminal activity
molestation
[Music]
[Music]
you